how do we find the surface area of a
cuboid this three-dimensional shape is
called a cuboid it is bounded by
rectangles from all
sides the most important thing we should
know about a cuboid is that it is
defined by its length breadth and height
we call them L B and H
respectively we now need to understand
how it surface area is
calculated its surface area will be the
sum of the areas of the six
rectangles we look at each rectangle
closely the area of the rectangle we see
in the front will be L multiplied H and
the area of the rectangle at the back
will also be L multiplied
H so the sum of these two will be LH
plus
LH let's remove these two now the area
of the rectangle at the bottom is L
multiplied B length multiplied by
breadth the area of the rectangle on top
will also be the same as that of the
bottom their sum will be lb plus
lb now let us take these two to the side
we have covered front and back top and
bottom what remains is the side faces
the sum of the areas of the rectangles
at the sides will be BH plus
BH area of each rectangle is base
multiplied by
height look at each group this will be 2
LH this will be 2 lb and this will be 2
BH so for a cuboid with lb and H as
Dimensions the surface area will equal 2
LH plus 2 lb plus 2
BH as 2 is a common factor to all the
terms we write it as 2 multiplied LH
plus lb plus
BH that's how simple the concept of
surface area is we just need to look at
each surface individually and add their
surface
areas within surface area there is a
concept of lateral surface area remember
one simple thing lateral means side so
this would actually mean the surface
area of rectangles at the sides there
are four such
rectangles this one this one this one
and the one at the back in terms of
surface area you can also look at
lateral as everything except the top and
the bottom the two green and the two red
rectangles make up the lateral
surface the lateral surface surface area
just equals the sum of the areas of
these four
rectangles the sum of the green
rectangles would be BH plus BH and the
sum of the red rectangles will be LH
plus
LH the total lateral surface area will
be twice LH +
BH where do we use this concept of
lateral surface area well here's one of
the
applications if you want the exterior of
your house painted you do not paint all
surfaces you just paint the sides not
the roof or the
[Music]
floor